we often hear the phrase
eat your rainbow and I'm a big advocate
on that what does it actually mean and
why is it important it is a simple way
of reminding us to consume a variety of
fruits and vegetables to get the
vitamins and minerals your body needs
the standard Western diet tends to fall
into the beige color just think of a
typical day porridge cereal granola
sausages pretzel sandwich pasta chicken
yeah you know what I mean
eating your rainbow means adding red
green yellow or orange purple blue and
white or brown fruits and vegetables
into your diet every single day each
color carries its own set of unique
healing properties which is called
phytochemicals it is these
phytochemicals that give these fruits
and vegetables its vibrant color and
healing properties we all know that we
should be consuming over five a day at
least three cups of vegetables and two
cups of fruits unfortunately most of us
only consume 1.8 cups a day eating a
rainbow is simple and it is actually the
first step you should take to get
healthy let's take a look at each color
red think of tomatoes strawberries
watermelon apples red peppers goji
berries cherries rice asuka beans red
quinoa and more red fruits and
vegetables are colored by a natural
plant pigment called lycopene lycopene
is a powerful antioxidant that can help
to keep your heart healthy and reduce
the risk of cancer especially prostate
cancer in a study of 50,000 men it was
found that men with the highest level of
lycopene with 21 percent less likely to
develop prostate cancer
in comparison to those with low levels
it can also prevent damage from
pesticides on our body not all of us can
afford organic produce free of pesticide
on a regular basis therefore it is very
important to consume red vegetables
fruits let's take a look at the next
color yellow and orange I'm sure you
have heard of eating your carrots being
good for your eyesight but why is that
so yellow and orange fruits and
vegetables are high in beta-carotene
which is converted to vitamin A in our
body vitamin A is important for
maintaining eye health boost immunity
and for cell growth to other carotenoids
are also present in yellow orange fruits
lutein and zeaxanthin
this helps prevent age-related eye
degeneration which can lead to blindness
just think of squashes carrots pumpkins
oranges lemons sweet potatoes peppers
yellow zucchinis mangoes papayas
cantaloupe and more another really
simple tip is to add a squeeze of lemon
juice to your food to increase iron
absorption plus it will add flavour to
your meal green vegetables are the most
common color we consume they are
extremely low in calories hence they can
help you to lose weight and to maintain
a healthy body weight plus they are
extremely high in fiber which means you
will feel fuller for longer green
vegetables have an abundance of vitamin
A C and K vitamin K is important to
protect your bones from osteoporosis
leafy greens like spinach and broccoli
are also rich in folate which is a B
vitamin especially important for
pregnant women to prevent birth defects
so besides consuming spinach and
broccoli other greens include bok choy
kill lettuce green grapes and apples
asparagus avocado kiwi fruit peas celery
and more let's move on to the next color
blue and purple unfortunately this food
group only makes up about 3% of the
average Western diet which tells us we
need to start increasing our intake in
these fruits and vegetables start to
consume more Bitteroot purple sweet
potato red cabbage eggplant blackberries
blueberries plums prunes
and purple grapes the plant pigment
anthocyanin is what gives blue or pulp
of fruits and vegetables they're
distinct unique color there is also some
anthocyanin in red fruits and vegetables
although it is not as present in
comparison to blue or purple fruits and
vegetables anthocyanin has antioxidant
property that protects cells from damage
and can have reduced the risk of cancer
stroke and heart disease anthocyanin
also promotes longevity here this wine
is high in anthocyanins rest virtual and
other flavonoids hence consuming wine in
small amounts can be good for your
health
flavonoids are also found in purple
sweet potato and it is one of the
reasons why the Japanese in Okinawa are
known for living a long and healthy life
and the final group is white and brown
white or brown vegetables are perhaps
the most neglected group of vegetables
although not technically a color of the
rainbow
what vegetables are rich in anthocyanins
a type of flavonoids and those and
things have been found to reduce blood
pressure in a ten-year study researchers
found that those who consumed white
fruits and vegetables regularly were 50%
less likely to get a stroke another
important element white and brown fruits
have is sulfur sulfur is important for
carotene which gives us hair and skin
their color a lack of sulfur will lead
to dull and saggy skin some white
vegetables such as garlic contains
allicin which has antimicrobial and anti
virus properties others such as bananas
and potatoes are a good source of
potassium so start adding cauliflower
mushroom garlic onions ginger bananas
parsnip turnips chickpeas and radish
into your diet the next time you shop
and cook think of the rainbow chart aim
to pack as many colors as you can into
your meals to start off consume at least
2 to 3 different colors of vegetables
and fruits in each meal and slowly
increase that
make your plate colorful and trust me
you will see the difference on your
waistline your health your body and also
your skin another tip is to create your
own rainbow smoothie by packing in all
the colors for example a blend of
strawberries mangoes spinach beetroot
and banana so guys it's your rainbow
every single day ok be sure to give this
video a thumbs up like this video share
this video on with all your friends and
hit the subscribe button for a lot more
fitness tips and nutritional advice
workout videos and colorful rainbow
recipes all the best